[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages
mit libri siri einen guten abend ihnen
allen katja stresow es war mir später
mit der samstags portion fußball so sei
es schon genannt und das haben wir unter
anderem für sie vorbereitet
russische angriffe auf den süden der
ukraine
gleichzeitig versuchen tausende das
belagerte mario polz zu verlassen
mehr eigenverantwortung heute enden fast
alle staatlichen vorgaben zum corona
schutz
und präsidentschaftswahlkampf in
frankreich emanuele makro führt die
umfragen an und mobilisiert seine
anhänger
die usa stocken ihre milliardenschwere
militärhilfe für die ukraine noch einmal
auf laut verteidigungsministerium sollen
unter anderem raketensysteme drohnen und
maschinengewehren wert von 300 millionen
dollar geliefert werden in der ukraine
selbst versucht man so viele zivilisten
wie möglich zu evakuieren eine
lebensgefährliche aufgabe zwischen
hoffen und bangen wie pablo salahi und
sarah alaska am beispiel der
eingekesselten stadt mario pohl zeiten
endlich in sicherheit zumindest sie
haben es geschafft aus mario pohl
herauszukommen in organisierten bussen
oder mit dem privaten pkw doch der
vereinbarte flucht korridor wurde erneut
beschossen
hier war der erste anschlag und hier
dann der zweite und vor uns ging eine
granate nieder
heute soll sich ein weiterer konvoi des
roten kreuzes auf dem weg nach mario
pohl gemacht haben in der stadt soll
noch mindestens 100.000 menschen
ausharren ohne strom und fließendes
wasser vor dem krieg lebten 450.000
menschen hier
kämpfe werden aktuell vor allem aus dem
süden des landes gemeldet wie hier in
einer rosa in unmittelbarer nähe des
atomkraftwerks mit sechs reaktorblöcken
das leistungsstärkste europas
aus der region um den ehemaligen meiler
von tschernobyl haben sich die russen
zurückgezogen nach ukrainischen angaben
hätten sich die soldaten dort radioaktiv
kontaminiert eine abordnung der
internationalen atomenergiebehörde
machte sich daraufhin vor ort ein bild
wir haben davon gehört dass einige
mitarbeiter kontaminiert wurden aber wir
haben dafür keine bestätigung und wir
haben eine ganze menge expertise hier im
haus was das angeht
in der region um die hauptstadt hier
sollen die russischen truppen weiter auf
dem rückzug sein der flughafen rostock
seit beginn des krieges stark umkämpft
soll wieder unter ukrainischer kontrolle
stehen präsident selensky geht davon aus
dass sich die angriffe jetzt weiter auf
den osten konzentrieren
im osten bleibt die situation extrem
kompliziert russische truppen rücken in
den don was vor und richtung charkiw sie
bereiten neue angriffe vor wir bereiten
eine effektivere verteidigung vor
zerstörte wohnhäuser verlassene straßen
wie hier in sumy im nordosten sieht es
in vielen städten der ukraine aus
jörg brase ist für uns in lemberg jörg
gerade im beitrag gehört die ukraine
fürchtet den vormarsch russischer
truppen richtung osten was hören sie
ja das scheint tatsächlich so zu sein
wir sind natürlich angewiesen auf
meldungen die wir von internationalen
sicherheitsbehörden und vom ukrainische
militär bekommen der ukrainische
generalstab hat gesagt in den
vergangenen 24 stunden hätten es
besonders heftige angriffe in den
provinzen raki flug gans und dann jetzt
gegeben wo eben auch die stadt mario
pohl liegt aber sollen auch eine
eisenbahnlinie eine gas pipeline
getroffen worden seien russische truppen
so sagt der generalstab zöge sich im
osten des landes also in den provinzen
entlang der russischen grenze zusammen
würden versuchen ukrainische einheiten
einzukesseln und gleichzeitig wir haben
es gehört werden russische einheiten aus
der umgebung der hauptstadt kiew
abgezogen das heißt im moment sieht es
so aus dass sich tatsächlich das
bewahrheitet was russland was moskau vor
wenigen tagen angekündigt hatte nämlich
dass man sich jetzt voll auf die
sogenannte befreiung des donners
konzentrieren will danke für diese
information live aus lemberg jörg brase
war das
für das aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
sind inzwischen schon
129 millionen euro spenden für die
menschen in der und aus der ukraine
zusammen gekommen die meisten die das
land verlassen haben die sind nach polen
geflohen hier unterstützt die
evangelische diakonie allein 50 projekte
mit diesen spenden manchmal sind es nur
kleine maßnahmen die für die menschen
aber viel bewirken aus krakau berichtet
isabel de la vega victoria matlok ist
diakon in der evangelischen gemeinde in
krakau eigentlich ist die seelsorgerin
doch die flüchtlinge aus der ukraine
verändern so vieles
heute wird gebastelt morgen schauen wir
ukrainische märchen an die ich zwar
nicht verstehe aber die ablenkung ist
wichtig für die kinder
als die ersten flüchtlinge in krakau
eintreffen zögert die gemeinde nicht
lange zwei große räume werden zu
schlafsälen umfunktioniert die küche
instand gesetzt und neue bäder
installiert in krakau leben mittlerweile
150 tausend flüchtlinge die stadt ist
mit ihren aufnahme einrichtungen an der
belastungsgrenze die 40 plätze hier in
der gemeinde sind begehrt man kümmert
sich hier um uns wie in einer familie
wir bekommen unterstützung für
verwaltungs anträge schulsachen für die
kinder manche gehen schon auf polnischen
schulen und auch das organisiert die
gemeinde ich glaube nicht dass das alles
möglich wäre wenn wir privat
untergebracht wären
victoria matlok kennt kaum noch pausen
gemeindemitglieder wollen wissen welche
sachspenden noch gebraucht werden und
die stadt ob noch ein bett frei wäre die
regierung hilft natürlich auch aber es
ist alles recht bürokratisch die
menschen brauchen ja sofort
unterstützung ein dach über dem kopf die
möglichkeit sich zu waschen darauf kann
man nicht warten bis anträge ausgefüllt
sind die kinder bekommen hier polnisch
unterricht parallel geht es weiter mit
dem schulstoff auf ukrainisch die kinder
machen weiter hier mit ihrer
ukrainischen lehrer er ist im ausland
und gibt von dort aus online unterricht
darauf dass alle länger bleiben müssen
stellt sich auch victoria matlok ein und
versucht den flüchtlingsfrauen ein
gefühl von würde und zuversicht zu geben
ja jede menge geflüchtete brauchen noch
jede menge hilfe und so ging es über das
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
bahn.de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine und alles
für sie zum nachlesen auch auf spenden
punkt zdf.de und auf der zdf textseite
vor allem das wissen sie energiepreise
haben sich durch den krieg und massiv
verteuert der chef der bundesnetzagentur
fordert in der frankfurter allgemeinen
sonntagszeitung dass privathaushalte
schon jetzt höhere monatliche abschläge
auf ihren verbrauch zahlen sollten
erhöhe man die abschläge erst nächstes
jahr treffe es viele menschen
unvorbereitet so behördenchef klaus
müller
jetzt zu corona da sinken die
infektionszahlen in deutschland weiter
bundesweit meldet das rk ii 196 1456
neuinfektionen binnen eines tages
55 1570 weniger als vor einer woche
außerdem kamen innerhalb eines tages
292 todesfälle hinzu die sieben tage
incidents ist leicht gesunken auf etwa
1.500 31
an diesem wochenende ist es in fast
allen bundesländern so weit die meisten
gesetzlichen corona schutzmaßnahmen
laufen aus und was dann bleibt ist ein
basisschutz außerhalb von hotspot
regionen soll es eine masken pflicht nur
noch begrenzt geben etwa in kliniken in
pflegeheimen in bussen oder bahnen für
die meisten bereiche aber gilt jetzt die
2g die 3g regeln und die masken dürfen
fallen oliver deuker mit einem
stimmungsbild aus hannover zwei jahre
pandemie zwei jahre einschränkungen doch
jetzt eine zeitenwende in den meisten
bereichen fällt die masken pflicht also
ich freue mich natürlich dass
lockerungen kommen aber ich sehe das
ganze auch so ein bisschen skeptisch
dass ich denke ich mir nach wie vor muss
getragen auf zb supermarkt also ich
finde es gut dass das in die
individuelle verantwortung jedes
einzelnen abgegeben wird wenn man was
getragen wird und so wir sie tragen wenn
nicht so etwas lassen muss ich das
selber wissen beruhigend wenn ich schon
sterben immer noch jeden tag 200 bis 300
leute eine mittelständische firma in
hannover der chef hier nutzt sein
hausrecht besteht weiter auf maske
tragen bei betreten seiner firma und in
der kantine
dass wir hielten das für inkonsequent
und für wenig schlau wenn wir auf die
masken pflicht verzichten wir haben hier
einen krankenstand erheblich ist knapp
unter zehn prozent im öffentlichen
personennahverkehr beim arzt in
krankenhäusern und altersheimen besteht
aber weiterhin masken pflicht dieser
basis schutz reicht aber nach meinung
von patientenschützer nicht aus gefährde
die wunde rebellengruppen stichwort
corona test hier bedarf es der täglichen
test für die mitarbeiter vor
dienstbeginn
das gibt es aber nicht und somit zieht
sich das leiden und sterben weiter fort
hohe inzidenz tten führen dazu dass
täglich mehrere hundert menschen stärken
die wir eigentlich gut schützen können
die kostenlosen schnelltests für
jedermann wird es aber noch weiterhin
geben vorerst bis ende juni die neuen
lockerung zu früh zu inkonsequent
kritisieren viele fachleute die jetzt
den frühling schon vor dem nächsten
herbst warnen
ab morgen gelten die neuen core ohne
regeln warum werden manche bundesländer
zu hot spots erklärt und andere nicht
also welche kriterien sind entscheidend
dazu finden sie in unserer zdf heute app
eine ausführliche bestandsaufnahme
wir schauen jetzt nach frankreich dort
findet in gut einer woche die
präsidentschaftswahl statt emanuele
makro will weiter im amt bleiben seine
wahrscheinlichste konkurrentin in einer
möglichen stichwahl ist die
rechtspopulistin marin lippen makro
präsentierte sich in den letzten wochen
als krisenmanager im ukraine krieg erst
jetzt steigt der amtsinhaber mit einer
einzigen großen veranstaltung in den
wahlkampf ein thomas walde aus paris
der präsident betritt die arena
die wucht des auftritts die inszenierung
sollen zeigen emanuel macau ist da in
den vergangenen wochen konzentrierte er
sich fernab der öffentlichkeit auf den
krieg in der ukraine heute ganz auf die
innen und sozialpolitik macom
verteidigte seine bilanz die
arbeitslosigkeit sei historisch niedrig
er kündigte programme für mehr soziale
gerechtigkeit und bessere
aufstiegschancen an
durch arbeit durch produktion können wir
in den kommenden fünf jahren unser
wachstum steigern mehr wohlstand
schaffen und den fortschritt fortsetzen
[Musik]
marien präsidentin laut umfragen ist die
nationalisten marine le pen max
hauptkonkurrentin dass sie in der
vergangenheit wladimir putin verteidigte
will sie vergessen machen sie sammelt
die stimmen der unzufriedenen verspricht
die kaufkraft der arbeitenden menschen
zu erhöhen zuwanderung zu beschränken
was als obligatorische wiederwahl
emanuel markus angekündigt wurde erweist
sich als fake news es ist wirklich
möglich emanuel makro zu schlagen
unter zahlreichen linken kandidaten jean
luc mélenchon als der aussichtsreichste
mindestlohn weniger arbeitszeit höhere
steuern für gutverdiener und rente schon
ab 60 - schon weil radikale
veränderungen die franzosen müssen
absolut souverän sein wir verteidigen
uns ganz allein darum haben wir nach
meiner meinung nichts in der nato zu
suchen die kandidatin der einstmals
bedeutenden sozialistischen und
konservativen parteien gelten als
chancenlos
so zeichnet sich in frankreich eine wahl
ab zwischen einem weiter so und
radikaler veränderung
zu einem anderen urnengang und damit
zurück nach deutschland genauer
schleswig holstein noch gut fünf wochen
bis zur landtagswahl dort
ministerpräsident günther von der cdu
liegt nach jüngsten umfragen deutlich
vorn gefolgt von spd und den grünen
demnach würde es für eine zweite
amtszeit der schwarz grün gelben jamaika
koalition reichen denkbar wären aber
auch andere bündnisse vom
wahlkampfauftakt in kiel herrmann bernd
im kieler landtag wird der wahlomat
freigeschaltet auch
cdu-ministerpräsident daniel günther ist
dabei nach jüngsten umfragen hat er gute
chancen sein amt zu behalten
er ist mit großem abstand beliebteste
politiker im land sein wahlkampfmotto
kurs halten ich meine ziele sind dass
wir ein weiterregieren ich würde sagen
gibt es eine jamaika koalition auch
weiter regieren weil ich fest davon
überzeugt bin dass die letzten fünf
jahre gute jahre für schleswig holstein
waren dass wir das land gut regiert
haben
spd-spitzenkandidat thomas lohse müller
setzt auf rot grün oder einer ampel mit
der fdp bis vor kurzem war noch mitglied
der grünen jetzt ist der genosse sein
problem er ist im land noch nicht so
bekannt so ein wahlkampf ist der hat
jetzt erst begonnen und das heißt die
zeit in der man bekannt für die fängt
jetzt erst an das ist eben so wenn man
als quereinsteiger mit erfahrung von
außerhalb der politik in die politik
kommt spitzenkandidatin der grünen ist
monika heinold die finanzministerin in
der jamaika koalition möchte
ministerpräsidentin werden ihr kernthema
ist der klimaschutz vor allem der
weitere ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
nach der wahl sehen wir was möglich ist
mit unseren programmen sagen der sehr
klar dass wir eigenständig sind dass es
keine koalitionsaussage vor der wahl
gibt wirtschaftsminister buchholz geht
für die fdp ins rennen er will vor allem
die digitalisierung vorantreiben und den
straßenbau und bildung investieren und
jamaika fortsetzen wir haben noch ein
bisschen was zu tun wir kommen ja fanden
so ausgangspositionen 98 9% und wir
wollen mehr selbstbewusst dritter
südschleswigsche wählerverband auf im
norden von der fünf prozent hürde
befreit hält man sich alle optionen
offen also die schließe gar nichts aus
sondern erst mal gesagt geht es darum
bundesergebnis von ssw und bereitschaft
besteht mit allen demokratischen
parteien zu reden die umfragen sie in
die afg und ihren spitzenkandidaten jörg
nobis wieder sicher im landtag mein ziel
wäre eine 7 vorm komma noch besser
werden vorm komma aber ich weiß dass die
bäume nicht in den himmel wachsen am 8
mai wird im norden gewählt der wahlkampf
jedenfalls kommt jetzt richtig auf
touren
papst franziskus denkt darüber nach die
einladung ukrainischer politiker
anzunehmen und nach kiew zu reisen das
sagte er zu beginn seiner balkanreise
franziskus verurteilte den krieg als
infantile und zerstörerische aggression
wichtiges thema bei seinem besuch ist
die migration
sie verlangen nach gemeinsamen antworten
so der papst ist dürfe nicht sein dass
nur einige länder das gesamte problem
tragen müssen
für die gläubigen muslime hat der
islamische fastenmonat ramadan begonnen
in mekka in saudi arabien versammelten
sich die pilger zum gebet und umrundeten
die kaaba das wichtigste heiligtum des
islam während des ramadan verzichten
gläubige tagsüber auf essen und trinken
nach islamischer überlieferung wurde den
propheten mohammed im fast monat der
koran offenbart weltweit gibt es etwa
1,9 milliarden muslime
wir machen jetzt mit dem sport und katja
und fußball weiter wir beginnen mit der
fußball bundesliga und da es in der
partie freiburg gegen die bayern knapp
60 minuten nach einer nullnummer aus
dann aber drehten die münchner auf hier
die ergebnisse des 28 spieltags die
bayern gewinnen also in freiburg 4 zu 1
leverkusen härter 2 zu 1 hoffenheim
unterliegt bochum 1 zu 2 frankfurt und
reuter führt trennen sich torlos 1 1
endergebnis zwischen bielefeld und
stuttgart am abend das topspiel dortmund
gegen leipzig mit erster free tv bildern
und allen wichtigen stimmen im aktuellen
sportstudio und bereits gestern union
berlin gegen erster fc köln 1 zu 0 in
der tabelle die bayern jetzt neun punkte
vor dem bvb der am abend aber wieder
verkürzen kann dahinter bis platz sechs
keine veränderungen zur vorwoche union
berlin schiebt sich an köln und
frankfurt vorbei auf rang sieben mainz
mit zwei spielen weniger an der spitze
der zweiten tabellenhälfte bochum und
gladbach auf 11 und 12 tauschen die
plätze genauso wie bielefeld und hertha
im keller schlusslicht greuther fürth
zu gast im aktuellen sportstudio ist
heute abend felix zweier der fifa
schiedsrichter gibt einblicke in die
guten aber auch in die schlechten seiten
seines jobs spricht über anfeindungen
und drohungen los gehts 23 uhr thema
dann auch die auslosung zur fußball wm
in katar gestern abend die entscheidung
deutschland bekommt es in der
gruppenphase mit spanien japan und costa
rica oder neuseeland zu tun spannend
interessant reizvoll attestierte unter
anderem der bundestrainer
losfee lothar matthäus mit einem
süffisanten lächeln bundestrainer hansi
flick mit bemühter coolness spanien als
gruppengegner da fällt einem sofort das
0 6 vom november 2020 ein und beim
letzten wm duell 2010 verwehrte spanien
mit einem 1 0 im halbfinale deutschland
den finaleinzug
die vergangenheit interessiert mich null
komma null es geht jetzt darum dass wir
einfach neu angefangen haben neustadt
gehabt und bis jetzt hat die mannschaft
ist sehr gut umgesetzt und wir wollen
jetzt spiel für spiel einfach uns normal
und sich verbessern ein wunschgegner ist
deutschland aber auch für die spanier
nicht
okay das ist wie ich die beste
mannschaft die man bekommen konnte
deutschland war das stärkste team für
mich aus topf 2 aber wie auch immer alle
mannschaften sind hier weil sie große
mannschaften haben japan und entweder
costa rica oder neuseeland zählen zu den
sogenannten machbaren aufgaben
überraschungspotenzial ist aber auch bei
diesen gegnern nicht ausgeschlossen
bisschen zeit ist noch november dezember
dann die spielzeit ich kann mich immer
noch nicht dran gewesen dankeschön galt
ja so es gibt ein bisschen neuschnee im
süden einige schauer im norden
dazwischen auch sonne meer
sonntagswetter gleich mit katja honnefer
das heute journal mit den neuesten
informationen um 21 uhr 45 mit christian
sievers das gesamte 19 uhr team sagt
schönen dank schönen abend und bis
morgen
[Musik]
guten abend umzingelt von gleich sechs
teams nimmt das hoch quincy reißaus in
richtung azoren und hier kommt schon ein
neues stürmisches tieferen dass uns dann
am wochenanfang beehrt jetzt müssen erst
mal die schneefälle nach in
süddeutschland die ziehen sich im laufe
der nacht immer mehr richtung alpenrand
zurück und von nordwesten kommen schon
neue schnee regen und regenschauer auf
dazwischen aber ist es klar und dann
sinken die temperaturen hier im
nordhessischen bergland im
rothaargebirge oder auch im sauerland
bis auf minus zehn grad da gibt es also
noch einmal strengen frost frostfrei
bleibt es dagegen an den küsten von ost
und nordsee die höchsttemperaturen
morgen liegen in bayern bei 1 bis 3 grad
sonst werden 4 bis 8 grad erreicht und
morgen vormittag kann es im allgäu noch
die letzten schneeflocken geben sonst
wird es freundlich aber über
norddeutschland ziehen doch endlich
regen und schnee regenschauer hinweg und
dann wird es wenn nicht dann kommen
diese stürmische tiefer montag heran
besonders an der nordseeküste pfeift ein
böiger wind aus westlichen richtungen
der dienstag wird dann recht verregnet
der mittwoch deutlich milder bei 7 bis
15 grad schönes wochenende